on peut commencer pas de problème en
plus j'ai tout mon temps j'aime bien
votre émission
alors alors d'où venez-vous
d'abord c'est quoi la famille
l'entourage la Renardière tiens c'est
quoi quoi tu connais pas la Renardière
c'est génial ça fait des centaines
d'années qu'on est là-bas on est ravi
l'été on fait des grandes tablées on est
m en plus on retrouve tout le temps les
tas de cousins ni Colin de maman qu'on a
pas vu depuis des années qu'on dé bit
énorme
h je voulais savoir avec ce
spectacle ça doit être difficile d'avoir
un moment pour soi pour s'occuper de de
sa maison non oh ben je commence mon
linge au dimanche matin comme ça c'est
bien j'ai ma journée oui je fais mes
laénages à la main le matin puis après
manger je fais mes
machines en général j'en fais une à 40
puis de à 90 oui ah oui ah oui moi tout
ce qui est culotte je fais bouillir